so this is being a while coming because
when did you actually get told you are
Aquaman I just found it in September
23rd 2013 and I was literally broke and
I knew that my future would be bright
but I couldn't say anything to anyone
for years I can't hold a secret to save
my life if you knew me it was like it
was very hard for me a little secret and
yeah well finally we're here but yeah
five years well six years they take that
long to make it no I had to go to like
Batman vs Superman one scene then it's
Justice League and now it's finally me
yeah
yes every scenes my time yeah I'm saying
damn
[Laughter]
we we don't have not get squealing
I'm trying to hold back and what and
this film is going to put to bed all
those things about Aquaman because
Aquaman up to this point in the DC world
what was a slight he's liked her a fun
yeah yeah they made fun of him and I was
hired to uh which I feel like I should
reward yes yes the lamest superhero and
kind of made him cool in the comics he
was not that cool this is exact state or
told me man and that's the image that
went through my head I've seen this
picture
I mean origin of white where Aquaman
came from it is you gotta see what he
went through as a child and his mother
Nicole Kidman she was here a few weeks
ago yeah yeah so yeah you get to see
where he comes from and I think a lot of
people can relate to it in this day and
age there's a lot of and also what's
great is and you watching it must have
had the same kind of thrill that we do
because it swirls
we haven't seen before you you're
blowing them up but we have them seen
them before
and presumably when you watch the film
you're thinking oh I didn't know that
was going to look like that yeah it's
even better cuz I haven't seen it yet so
it's gonna be like wait a minute you are
the star of a movie and you haven't
bothered to watch it yet here's the
thing I have two babies that are 10 and
11 there with me the whole time
and they promised me I wouldn't watch it
tell us other thing oh so they're so
cute and they were there with me the
whole time and I'm like I promise you
guys will see it before all of us yeah
but my little crazy be wrong they're on
set with me and I just I want to hold
their hands and it's such a rare moment
being a father it's especially for me
cuz generally you can't watch the things
that I do children should watch what I
do
made a solid profession out of that and
I just feel like you know this is
something I want to show my children
just in case we get letters I should
well I hope say you haven't actually
tattooed your children Graham I haven't
tattooed my chil that's all right
those are stickers you're disappointed
yeah I was thinking that's pretty cool
that ya wanna be watching that guy
why don't we want to get a tattoo me
[Music]
you